We're talking about facts,
ideas,
and words in relation to Stereo Chemistry.
And the words have to be generalized that in the way we communicate things,
uh,
to include models,
things like this.
Alright.
And let me turn that microphone off right here.
I'll
do it.
Uh,
got to remember how to turn it off.
Okay,
there we go.
Can you,
Okay.
So models,
but also what you can draw on a piece of paper that will convey stereo chemical
structure to people.
So the standard we use in drawing is wedges.
Demean their coming out at you in the direction that they expand.
And Day does mean they're going back into the board.
Although all you draw is damages.
It's not immediately obvious which end is going back if it's a dash,
right?
But if one end has nothing on it,
it's clear,
right?
That it's going back from the carbon that's shown.
So you have to use your stereo chemical intuition sometimes to interpret that.
Although if you draw a wedge,
it's clear which way it's coming.
And,
uh,
sometimes people draw wedges with dots meeting,
they're going back in.
But there are many ways that people make mistakes in dryness,
so it needs a little practice.
That one's okay and clearly corresponds to a tetrahedron with hundred nine
degree bond angles shown like this.
Right?
The blue ones coming out at you?
The black,
the yellow one's going back green and red up and down.
Okay,
so that drawing is fine.
What's wrong with this drawing?
Yeah,
sure.
What?
I can't hear it.
I still can't hear.
What are the bond bangles?
How about between the solid lines?
109 and a half degrees
between the solid lines.
Just not the wedges.
Oh,
on 880 how about the other angles?
90 bright.
This is a play.
This is a square plain drawn that way.
The day she has to go the other way and it's,
and the,
the lines that are in the plane of the board or the piece of paper have to be at
109 degrees.
Okay,
so that,
forget that one.
I assure you that we will get these on on exams because we always have in the
past.
But this is warning.
Okay.
So that one's playing or forget that.
How about one there?
I've got the wedges drawn the right way.
Everything else,
right?
No,
the solid lines in the plane are 180 degrees.
That one's bad.
Obviously not many people draw it that way.
Okay.
Oh,
there's one that looks pretty good.
Yeah.
Everybody agree?
Any complaints?
Lucas?
What's the complaint?
Pardon me.
Ah,
the angles between the lines,
the SA,
the normal lines on the wedge are all less than than 90 degrees.
Well,
one of them is bigger than 90 degrees.
The ones at the top,
but the one to the bottom is less than 90 degrees if the normal line is in the
plane of the screen.
All right.
That's an acute angle,
right?
So the one on the top left is the one you want to go for.
Okay.
Now how about this?
Yeah,
those look good.
See any problems?
Okay.
And what do you say?
It looks fine to you.
Tell me what the angle is here between this bond
and this one.
Where would this bond point?
If it were 90 degrees from this one,
which is in the plane of the board,
would point straight out now that if at 90 degrees it would be coming straight
out from that point.
How about there is this angle greater than or less than 90 degrees?
Here's the one.
Here's the one that said,
here's the carbon.
Here's the one that's in the plane of the board,
right?
It's going like,
like that.
Here's the one that's 90 degrees,
right?
Suppose I bend it up like this,
which is what the wedge shows.
Now,
what's the angle?
The cute,
right?
So these are not right,
The same is true at the bottom,
but this structure is okay because by convention it doesn't mean to show the
exact angle.
It just means to show that it's going relatively out,
right?
But it wouldn't be the,
the solid,
these three lines here,
this one,
this one.
The ones that are not wedges and not die,
she just could not be in the plane of the board.
They'd be 120 degree angles or something like that.
They couldn't be a 109 right?
But in order to draw this in a finite amount of time,
when you're writing on paper,
people understand what you mean in this case.
But if you draw that one,
which means it's playing or people will be very much offended,
right?
Okay.
This again,
at a certain level is lore.
You have to find,
be criticized before you find out where you're making mistakes,
okay?
But anyhow,
it's important to be sensitive about the fact that carbon is tetrahedral.
Now,
uh,
these things are hard to do in three dimensions.
And the Fischer projection was invented for that purpose in 1891.
And the reason for its invention was,
was,
uh,
was interesting.
He wrote with the help of freed lenders,
convenient rubber models.
One can construct molecules of right handed tartaric acid,
lefthanded,
tartaric acid and inactive tartaric acid and lay them in the plane of the paper
so that the four carbon atoms are in a straight line and the attached hydrogens
and hydroxyls lie above the plane of the paper.
Now here's the idea that freed lenders,
models use rubber tubing to connect these things,
right?
So drawing this in in two dimensions and making clear what you mean in three is
not easy,
but he says what you're going to do is take the four carbons that are in a
chain.
This is tartaric acid right here is to a carbon with an o h carbon with an o h
and the carbon with o two on it,
right?
So what he wants to do is to lay it all four carbons in the plane of the paper,
which you can't do,
right?
But if the bonds are made of rubber,
then you can bend the bonds,
right?
Okay.
And then you can make them all four in the plan to the paper,
right?
But
what you have to understand is that in this convention,
you draw the four carbons vertical in a line,
not horizontal.
And then you understand that the bonds between them are severely bent,
right?
So the,
the curious thing is that when you draw a Fischer projection,
as is most convenient for sugars,
discuss pops.
Pardon me?
Uh,
we're discussing the configuration of sugars,
the bond,
the four bonds for this carbon are understood that these two,
the horizontal ones come out toward you as if they were wedges and the other two
from this carbon go back into the board.
Okay,
this is his paper.
Where are you originally proposed it nowadays you wouldn't use dots here,
which help make it clear that it's going back.
You just draw lines,
but understand that vertical lines mean they're going back into the board and
horizontal lines mean they're coming out at you.
Okay,
so that's the Fisher convention that he invented in 1891.
So this is a,
so this bond here is a very funny bond because in bonding from this carbon and
this carbon,
it's going back into the board from this carbon,
but also back into the board from that carbon because it's been okay.
And it was because free blender made his models with rubber tubing that it
occurred to Fisher that you could do this and then all you have to do is draw
straight lines.
You don't have to do wedges and so on and just put things in the right place.
So here he could draw right handed tartaric acid,
lefthanded,
tartaric acid and inactive,
or Miso as we call it now tartaric acid.
So the attached hydrogens and hydroxyls lie above the plane of the paper,
right?
And the other carbons vertical bonds go back in from both of the atoms that they
attach.
Okay?
So that they're the wedges.
And if you rotate that 90 degrees,
it would look like that very highly distorted.
But you can do it with rubber and steel and be clear about what the
configuration is on ambiguous.
Okay?
They go back from both carbons and it was because you had rubber models that you
could do that.
Okay?
Okay.
So here are those models and notice that you can rotate in plane by a 180
degrees and it means the same thing.
So if I have this and it's bent like this and I rotate it like that 180 degrees,
it's obviously means the same thing,
right?
I can rotate a Fischer projection by 180 degrees and it's still the same model,
but I can't rotate it by,
I can't rotate it by 180 degrees or by by 90 degrees this way.
Why not?
If I wrote,
write it this way,
it won't mean the same thing.
Why not
shy?
Yeah.
The horizontal bonds are going back in and the vertical ones are coming out at
you.
You've reflected it in a mirror,
each carbon,
so you can rotate it 180 degrees,
but you can't rotate it 90 degrees.
Okay.
Uh,
so there,
we'll rotate that 180 degrees.
That's still fine.
And in fact,
what do you notice about it other than the fact that the,
the,
the symbols are written backwards.
Yeah,
it's the same thing.
It was above,
right?
So rotated at 180 degrees doesn't change it.
Okay.
How about the next one?
If you rotate it 180 degrees,
same as above.
Yep.
How about the last one?
Right.
That one is now the mirror image.
If you slide it up like that,
you can see that there would be a mirror there.
Everybody with me?
So that molecule is its own mirror image.
Yeah.
Whereas the first two and memory,
you can draw the mirror any direction and always get the same mirror and same
mirror image x,
y,
Y,
Z,
z.
They all give the same mirror image just differently oriented.
Another way to draw the mirror,
one that's easier is to draw it right through the middle of the molecule
horizontally.
Then the top path is the mirror image of the bottom right.
So it's obviously not a chiral molecule.
It's super imposable on its mirror image.
Whereas the,
and that one's called Misa,
uh,
the name.
Then that was called Mezzo tartaric acid.
And the name was generalized to mean any molecule,
which is its own mirror image is me Zo.
Okay.
And notice that these,
these terms,
name relationships,
they don't name it,
absolute molecule,
these stereo chemical terms,
the ones like this,
what's the relationship between those two?
Are they identical
or are they just playing different or are they different than the special way
that they're mirror images of one another.
The two on the two on the top left.
All right.
Can you rotate them and make them be on top of one another?
No.
If you rotate them,
they become the same thing they were originally,
right.
That's what we already did.
Are they mirror images of one another,
right?
There's a vertical mirror between them.
Right?
So those are non superimposable mirror images and the name given to things like
that.
Is Ian Anti Omer.
So the one on the left,
the top left,
is that eating a anti Imr of the one that's in the middle?
Caitlin,
what's the question?
Yes.
Oh no,
but that's,
but all that means is the grouping c double bond o Ooh.
That doesn't have any arrangement in space when it's just written with letters
that way.
Okay.
That was just because I wanted to make strictly the rotation.
Right.
It's where the bonds point that makes a difference.
Okay.
Now how about the relationship between the middle and the right?
Are Those uh,
identical?
Are they super imposable
Elizabeth,
what do you think?
No,
you can't move.
Those are rotate them any way and make them on top of one another.
Are they mirror images?
So what are they?
They're just playing different.
Their Daya Steria Mers.
So the one in the middle is the ENA,
a tumor of the one on the left.
But the Daya Steria Burr of the one on the right.
So you don't say it's a Daya a stereo or it's an anti tumor.
You say it's a dye,
a stereotype of and the ne Ne Tumor of that.
Right.
So these name relationships.
Okay.
How about those two?
The first than the last.
What's the really proper relationship there?
Maria?
Right.
Dies there.
Amer good.
So we got the idea.
Okay.
Now how many,
uh,
I saw him isomers do you have,
obviously we have one chiral center you have right handed and left handed if
they're four different things on it.
So there are two isomers.
But suppose you have several chiral centers.
That's not so obvious.
Then how many of you have a,
so if you have n Stereo Magenic centers as they're called.
And each could be right or left.
Then you'd imagine the number of permutations would be two to the Nth,
right,
that that would be expected.
But that's not true because of miso compounds.
And we'll illustrate that with a quote from van Hoff's brochure in 1877 where he
said,
next we consider a symmetrical formula where carbon,
the first carbon has one,
two,
three.
The next one has two fours,
and the last one has one,
two,
three different substituents.
And also the one where the two in the middle are different,
four and five on the middle carbon as is easily conceived from the foregoing
discussion,
they lead to only three isomers because you have this possibility of Mezzo.
Okay.
That we just were talking about,
although this is with three centers,
possibly in the second one.
Now,
buyer and Fisher were a buyer.
Student of calculator was the,
was the teacher of Fisher and they got together on a,
at a resort on the shore of the Mediterranean,
uh,
the in,
in Italy.
And we're trying to figure out this particular question of how many isomers you
have here.
And they had red van Hoff's things,
so they knew that were supposed to be three isomers.
So they were sitting at breakfast and they had bread rolls and they had
toothpicks.
So they started making models of these,
I'm trying to count how many isomers,
but they ran out of bread rolls presumably and couldn't answer the questions.
They were completely flummoxed by trying to understand what van Hoff was saying.
So they gave up on using bread rolls and that is what prompted Fisher to go back
and figure out how to make Fischer projections.
Okay,
now let's look at that particular case using Fischer projections.
So we have these three carbons that might have four different things on them.
The one in the middle is a little bit tough to decide because the ones on as to
whether it has four different things,
obviously it has h o h and a carbon,
but those carbons that are attached are identical.
Constitutionally.
They have the same nature and sequence of bonds,
things attached to them,
but they might or might not be the same from the point of view of
stereochemistry.
So it's not so obvious how this is gonna work out,
but it turns out that it's really easy if you use Fisher projections,
and we'll try it here.
So here are the five carbons in a row,
the top and the bottom on being coh is,
and you have the three carbons in the middle,
each of which has an h and an o h on it.
But they could be either way.
So at first glance it looks like two to the third right,
or eight possible isomers.
So let's check them out.
Instead of using bread rolls using Fischer projections.
So we'll draw eight Fisher projections and try to be systematic and draw all the
possibilities and then count them.
Okay,
so first we'll take the bottom a carbon and we'll put in the top row,
all the ohs to the right and in the bottom row,
all the ohs to the left.
And then we'll do the analogous thing with the second row,
except we'll make the first two to the right,
the next two to the left,
the next two to the right,
the next two to the left.
Okay.
And finally,
what are we going to do on the top row?
Can you see how we're going to,
so that we get all eight,
we'll go right,
left,
right,
okay.
And now we've got all the possibilities.
So now we have to go through them one by one and see if they're unique or how
they are related to the others.
If they're related or they die.
Hysteria.
Mers,
are they enantiomers are they identical?
And we're going to use Fisher,
these Fisher projections to do it.
Okay,
so we've got the first one.
Okay.
And now we look at the second one and compare it to the first one.
Is it the same?
No.
Uh,
is,
are they a super imposable?
No,
that would make them the same.
Are they uh,
are they mirror images now?
So two is different,
right?
Their dietary IBMers.
Okay.
Now how about the next one?
Three.
Is it like any of the previous ones or the mirror image of any of the previous
ones?
No.
Three is unique.
Okay.
Now how about for,
does it look like any of the preceding ones?
Wilson?
Ah,
you can rotate it 180 degrees,
which you can allow.
Right.
That'll keep the bonds pointed back in the convention.
And it'll look like too.
So,
so that one actually is too.
So we'll blank it out.
Now.
How about the first one in the bottom row here?
Does it look like one?
No,
this isn't like three.
it's look like too.
Uh,
that's not so easy.
Right?
But it's not super imposable.
If you rotated 180 degrees,
right about the access into the screen,
it still doesn't look like too,
right.
So it's different for,
how about the next one,
Virginia?
You got an idea?
Does the,
does,
does this one here look like any of the previous ones?
If we rotate it
can't hear.
Uh Huh.
It's like three.
If we rotate it 180 degrees,
it's like three.
So forget that one.
How about the next one?
Does it look like anybody?
We've already seen
four,
right?
If you rotated 180 degrees,
it's four.
Okay.
And the last one?
Pardon me?
Like what do you say?
It's one if you rotated 180 degrees.
Okay,
so we've got these four that are different now.
What are the relationships?
Okay,
are any of the Mezzo,
do any of them have mirror planes so that their own,
they're their own mirror image.
Angela
one has a mirror image.
At the top is the mirror image of the bottom.
There's the mirror.
Any others?
Three.
Hey,
this but not to or for anything else that you want to note about two and four.
Sophie,
they're mirror images of one another.
Okay.
So what we have are to Misa isomers there diastema members of one another,
right?
And a pair of enantiomers.
Each of those enantiomers is the enantiomers of one another.
And the dietary them,
or of either of the previous ones?
One and three.
Okay.
So with Fisher projections,
he could easily settle this,
this question,
and that became very important in the chemistry of sugars were Fisher was deeply
involved as we'll see you next semester.
Okay.
Now here's Hallah Condron B,
which is,
which comes from a marine sponge as it says here.
Okay?
Now you don't get very much of this out of a sponge,
right?
But it was found that it was useful in an anticancer therapy.
So the hope was you could make it right and then see if it will work as a good
drug.
So it was found that you don't need the whole molecule.
If you cut it apart to have only this we've seen here,
then that part is just as good a medically as the whole molecule.
So that simplifies the synthesis problem quite a bit,
but it still nontrivial.
So there's the active fragment of how La Condron,
B and s ar means structure,
activity,
relationship.
They'd take off this,
take off that,
trim it here and so on and change one thing to another thing and see if you,
if you can get better activity than you get from just this thing itself.
And especially looking at the changes that would make it easier to synthesize.
Okay.
So they found out that this one,
which is called e seven three eight nine,
that model is about as easy as you can get to synthesize and still have really
good activity,
but it's not easy to synthesize and you have the question that you have to get
the right diet.
Astarria Merck as the other dietary mers are different.
Now,
how big a problem is that going to be?
Well,
it depends on how many stereo genic centers there are.
How many carbons can have generate two isomers right by being right or left
handed.
So let's start up here at the left and I'll go along this chain like that.
And you stop me when we get to a carbon that's,
that's a chiral.
That's stereo.
Genic okay,
so I'll start here at the top left and I'm going across.
Stop me when I get to one.
Well,
you didn't tell me that one looks at while you say,
oh,
that is only three things on it.
Yeah.
You have to have four different things to be stereo genic does anybody think
that one is stereo?
Agentic
Jan,
you
can't hear.
Oh,
it doesn't show the hydrogen,
the hydrogens aren't being shown.
So there are in fact four different things on that third,
third atom.
Nitrogen,
carbon.
The second carbon.
Is there a agentic.
Okay,
so there's one.
Now let's keep going.
How about here?
That one?
No,
that one is two hydrogens.
How about this one?
That's stereo.
Janet,
how about this one?
Yeah.
How about this one?
Hey,
how about this one?
Okay.
How about this one?
This one.
Ah,
that's got four bonds already know hydrogens there.
Okay.
That one's not there.
Here and there.
There,
there,
there?
Yeah.
That's got four there.
Yep.
There.
Yup.
For different things.
Because you have to count the hydrogen here.
Yup.
The hydrogen also that in the and shows the hydrogen.
All right here?
Yeah.
Here.
No.
Well,
you say there are two oxygens,
right?
Are they the same?
No.
They're attached to different things,
right?
So that one too.
Okay.
Here?
No.
Here.
How many things?
So Yup.
Right?
That one.
The next one.
This one?
Yes or no?
Here?
No.
Here.
Yes.
Speak Up.
And there's one more carbon here?
No.
Okay,
well done.
There are 19 stereo Magenic centers.
That means there are two to the 19th possible isomers.
Will any of them be Misa?
So are you going to get any mirror images within this molecule?
No,
it's completely unsymmetric right?
It's not like tartaric acid.
So they're going to be something like something greater than half a million
configurational isomers so it's not just a question of putting the right groups
in the right place to get constitution.
You have to put them stereo chemically.
Correct.
Right.
To get one out of a million.
So this is a problem,
but they figured out how to do it.
And this,
I just got this this morning off the web.
Uh,
pardon me.
It's a,
it'll say so at the top,
but this is the current report on clinical testing of this.
So testing in humans.
Some of them are in,
like if you look at the top one,
it's in phase three.
In phase one,
they test for toxicity with humans and obviously it's toxic.
You can't use it as a drug.
The next one they test does it work.
And the third they test whether it's better than current things for doing it and
what the proper dose should be and so on.
So this is in phase three trials and they're recruiting people to web,
sorry,
I've got the brush,
the ramen there recruiting subjects for it.
They already have 1100 people in it.
It started in June,
2006 and this was updated in uh,
last May and it's to,
doesn't have a completion date given there.
This one has a completion date of March,
2010,
but in fact,
this is the objective to see what the quality of life is.
Tumor response rate,
duration of response,
how many survived?
One,
two and three years in this,
I have breast cancer test and it's being compared with another drug as it says
there.
Uh,
so here.
So here's the,
uh,
what they're comparing the two different things.
Some people do this,
some people do this.
So the drug,
this drug is injected 1.4 milligrams per square meter,
ivy infusion over two to five minutes on days one and eight,
every 21 days.
And it's being compared with this drug,
which has two and a half grams per square meter per day administered orally,
twice daily,
and two equal doses,
blah,
blah.
Okay.
So that's the test that's under,
that's being undergone now.
And the estimated primary completion date is September,
2011.
It's been going since June,
2006.
So it's still going to be five years,
right?
That they're doing this test with 1100 people.
So these are really,
really expensive things.
And you notice it says it's being,
uh,
maybe it was on a previous slide that it's being funded by,
by industry because they hope that it'll work and then there'll be able to
recoup their costs and make a profit on the basis of selling the drug
afterwards.
Okay.
That if you go to this,
uh,
NIH website,
clinical trials.gov,
you find that they have 64,268 trials in 158 country a country's going as of
today.
So these are very,
very long,
expensive things to try to get a drug that will work.
But making that stuff was really something.
But if they get a hit,
then the company is on easy street for awhile,
at least like Lipitor.
So here's the Lipitor pill,
which is the world's best selling drug in 2004 it's sold almost $11 billion,
right?
And it's so,
but it raised a $10 billion problem in stereo chemical notation that I'll show
to you here.
So this is a news report from 2005 date line New York,
Pfizer Inc won a significant victory on Wednesday when a British judge upheld a
key patent country covering it's blockbuster cholesterol,
drug,
Lipitor,
and the United Kingdom.
But the medications still faces a similar yet more important case in the United
States.
And that was decided in 2006 in the same way in the u s Court of Appeals.
Okay.
So judge Nicholas Pumphrey in in the high court in London upheld the patent
covering a tour of a staton lip,
a tours active ingredient,
but ruled that another patent was invalid.
Indian pharmaceutical company ran Baxi laboratories limited.
A generic chemical company had challenged both patents and was joined by
Britain's Arrow.
Generics limited against the second patent that was ruled invalid.
Pfizer said the decision upholding the exclusivity of the patent covering a tour
of a Staton until November,
2011 was an important victory for scientists and perhaps also for stockholders
and executives of Pfizer.
Okay.
Now what is patented?
Here's the patent that was under discussion.
The,
this is the US version.
There was also a version.
Okay,
so let's patent number 4,681,893 from 1987.
so the,
the,
the important part of a patent is the claims at the end.
What's the be protected?
And it said,
I claim a compound of structural Formula One.
So this compound,
okay.
And notice that it has,
uh,
codes in here.
Like x can be any of those groups linking the right and the left are one can be
any of those groups are too in our three can be any of these groups
still going are four can be any of these groups or it can be a hydroxy instead
of being this kind of Esther,
which is called a lactone at forms a ring,
it could be the acid that you'd get from that by hydrolyzing it or assault of
that acid.
Okay.
So all those things are covered in that patent.
How many molecules are covered in the patent.
If you made all the permutations of those groups,
you'd find that it's greater than the number of protons,
neutrons and electrons in the solar system.
So it's obviously impossible to make all the molecules.
You'd need quite a few solar systems to have enough particles to do it with.
Okay.
But the patent is supposed to protect that.
Now,
uh,
so here we sh what's,
but what is patented and what was being discussed was not what those groups are.
That wasn't in con in contention.
It's known that Lipitor is this stuff,
the calcium,
salt.
And it has those particular our groups on it.
But that wasn't in question.
The fact that it covered so many compounds.
What was in question was what the Stereo chemistry is because Lipitor the drug
is a single lien antitumor
right now,
not it's mirror image and not a mixture.
Not Harassing me.
Okay.
But the question is did this patent cover the single Lien Angie Mar,
which is what the picture shows,
although it doesn't show it very well,
why not?
If you were drawing this structure on the top right,
would you draw it that way?
How about that carbon?
Does it show its tetrahedron?
Well it certainly doesn't show 190 degree angles,
but it's at this day should be up here,
right to be even close.
How about that carbon?
That's even worse if you are trying to really show the angle cause that one's
180 degrees,
but at least it's unambiguous about about that versus it's mirror image even
though it's not very good.
Right.
It's not ambiguous.
So the,
the,
the structure drawn in the patent was a singly Nan tumor and it turned out to be
the one that is Lipitor.
Okay.
But the text of the patent didn't,
didn't do anything it never resolved at and made it into one in antitumor.
Right.
It just,
it just talked about it generically and what it was,
what would be making is the Rasamayi not the single antivirus.
So does the patent cover Lipitor or doesn't,
was was the question for the judge.
Okay.
So this is his opinion.
He said the six three,
three patent,
they uh,
when they talk about patents,
they just talk a lot.
The last three digits,
not the big number.
It is absolutely clear from context throughout that Formula One is being used to
denote a Rasamayi.
So what they talked about,
what they prepared,
tested and so on was both he enantiomers.
Okay.
In my judgment,
every time the skilled person sees Formula One or formula 10,
now skilled person has a very special meaning.
It means someone who is skilled in the art that knows about pharmaceutical
chemistry and so on,
knows what these compounds are,
how to make them and that kind of thing but is not creative because what you can
patent his original creation.
So the skilled person knows everything but can't figure anything out if you see
what I mean.
Can't devise anything new.
Okay.
So the skilled person sees these formulas,
he will see them with eyes that tell him that in that Rasamayi which is
described in the text,
there is a single lien antitumor that is the effective compound.
So even though what's described as both the person that's,
that isn't very swift but,
but is knowledgeable,
knows that within that one there'll be two mirror images and one of them will do
the trick and not the other one.
So you don't have to be creative to know that and he will know that he can
resolve the Ras summate using conventional techniques.
He doesn't have to invent something new in order to get from that mixture.
The one that will be the active one.
Okay.
So that's not creative.
When one comes to claim one which echoes the purpose of the invention with its
conventional reference to pharmaceutically acceptable salts.
He will,
in my judgment,
continue to see the forum in this light.
So the salts,
same deal,
right?
In my view,
the claim covers the Ras,
a mate and the individually and antivirus.
So the person without any creativity knows that yes,
the patent described the Rasamayi,
but there'll be one in there that I can get and that'll be the useful drug and
it doesn't take anything great to get there.
We'll talk about that soon.
How you would do that,
why it's why it's well known.
Okay,
so this is good news for Pfizer,
right?
Their patent holds that.
They put out a press release saying this is a victory for science.
Okay?
But it's in a sense of pyrrhic victory because they had a later patent on the
single lien anti tumor,
right?
And now that patent is invalid because if the first patent covers it,
you can't just,
every three years come up and say,
I patent this again.
I patent this again,
I patent this again and keep getting another 15 years of exclusivity.
Right?
So once they were covered by the first patent,
the second patent isn't invalid.
Why do they care if they're already covered by the first patent?
Isn't that good news,
Dana?
Ah,
they're going to run out.
So this means that three years earlier,
their patents is going to run out right at four or $5 billion a year.
That makes it adds up.
Okay,
now,
so drug,
so there conventions for how you name things including Stereo Chemistry.
In fact,
there was a stamp issued in a,
in Switzerland in 1992 commemorating the 100th year of the Geneva Convention
where chemists got together.
Once they knew stuff about how things were connected,
then they had to agree on how to describe it on what the nomenclature and the
notation should be.
So the International Union of Pure and applied chemistry continues this and you
can go to these websites and learn about what the rules are for notation.
So the four.
So they had to devise rules for what you want to do when you make a name for a
compound.
So what,
what this may be the first thing you want to do,
Nate.
What?
No,
not yet.
Well,
let's see.
Let's try somebody else.
Andrew,
not known.
Kate.
Okay.
Hey,
what's,
what was the,
what was the first role being,
well,
no,
I didn't mean to you anyhow.
So what's the first rule about names?
Oh,
John,
not you.
Other Kate.
Ah,
they should be unique.
There should only be one person,
one,
one compound that has that name that you shouldn't say.
Take this and they take the wrong John or the wrong Kate or the wrong Andrew.
Right?
So the very first thing should,
well,
it shouldn't,
it should be Kate.
You were right.
The first,
it has to be clearly descriptive of what the compound is.
And so it has to tell composition,
constitution configuration and con formation.
Maybe if you care,
I he stereo chemistry and it can be like this e seven three,
eight,
nine was the name of that compound.
Forget trying to name it systematically according to rules.
Right?
He is for Asi,
the name of the pharmaceutical company,
and this is their 7389th compound.
Right?
But at least everybody knows what that means.
If you are,
you can look it up.
But this is what we were just talking about.
It has to be unambiguous,
right?
One name must mean one structure,
not some other structure as well.
Okay.
So unfortunately amid doesn't fit that bill because it means the anti and have
an a mean.
But it also means that functional group we're talking about,
so same name,
you have to figure out from context which one you're talking about.
It also has to be unique.
One structure is one name.
So everybody will have the same name for the compound,
right?
Is that which is more important that it'd be unambiguous or that it be unique?
Like you could have two names for the same compound,
like Bromo butane and beautiful bromide,
right?
And if you put a number in,
you would know which,
which were the bromine was okay.
Or Bromo Ethane and ethyl bromide.
Two different names.
Right?
So it's not you.
The names aren't unique,
right,
but they're unambiguous.
You know what compound you're talking about.
Why would you care whether you have on whether you have just one agreed on name
by the people who get together in the International Union of pure and applied
chemistry.
Why would you care what's wrong with having two names?
Anybody see any disadvantage to having different names for the same compound?
Sam?
I could called Sam to,
yeah,
go ahead.
Not if everybody knows what you're talking about.
Shy has a lot of names that
I'm actually here to get to a point where someone doesn't know.
You can say that you're going to say a name and they're not going to know group
or if you have to look it up,
you have to choose the right name to look it up.
So this was more important when you didn't have computers to do the work for
you.
When you had to look in an index and get and be looking for the right name that
everyone agreed and the person who made up the index entered it there.
Nowadays,
you can draw a structure often on the screen,
right in the,
and the computer will figure out what the official name is and then look it up.
But anyhow,
that's that,
that,
so it's not as important that it be unique is that it'd be unambiguous.
But if you're looking things up,
it's very nice if you know that everybody will have named it a certain way.
So you can also index things according to their composition or using computer
graphics as we say.
And if possible,
the name should be manageable,
right?
It should be possible to write it fairly quickly.
It should be easy to figure out short if possible and pronounceable if possible
so that you can talk about it.
Now let's look at a systematic constitutional nomenclature for this sort of
intermediate,
really complex compound compared to these others we've looked at.
It's not much.
Okay.
So the first thing you do,
these people decided when you get together is decide what the main chain of
carbons is cause that will provide the root with a Greek designation that says,
uh,
what the number of things in.
So we have to find a carbon chain and we'll find the longest carbon chain.
We could take this one
or we could take that one.
Which one is longer?
One.
It could be an octane or it could be a no name.
Which one should we choose?
Well,
if we could,
we could have decided to take the shortest one,
but that's sort of silly.
There'd be a zillion shortest ones or the short ones,
right?
Or even shortest.
The shortest is one carbon,
I guess,
but there's only one longest one.
Right?
Wrong.
Because there's also that one same length.
So now we have to decide when we,
when we're going to take the longest,
how are we going to choose if there are two of them?
Well,
what you choose by is the number of substituents.
Okay.
Because that one has one,
two,
three,
four,
five substituents and this one has four substituents,
which will you choose the one with four or the one with five?
You have to make the rule up
five or four.
Yeah.
Well,
somebody said for why
Sophie,
you said for there'd be less naming to do.
Aha,
but,
but in fact they chose the most substituents and you'll see why shortly.
Okay,
so you choose the most substituents.
So you choose the one on the top,
not the one in the middle.
Now why Sophie's not happy with this,
but you'll see soon.
Now you have to number the carbon atoms to say where the substituents are.
Now we could start from either end,
right?
If we start one,
we could go one,
two,
three with green and continue,
or one,
two,
three with red from the other end.
And continue.
Now how are we going to decide which way to go,
Kevin?
Okay,
there are two ways to do it.
You could make it so the overall,
some of the numbers you're going to get,
because you'll get different numbers according to which can just start from,
you could sum them all up and see which one gives the lowest som and choose that
one or the highest psalm you could do.
Or You could see which one gives the f the lowest number at the first number.
So this,
if you chose the red,
you'd have to chloro.
If you chose the green,
you'd have three Bromo.
Right.
And the other numbers would all be higher.
Which one do you want to do?
Use the,
the lowest.
Some of all the numbers or the lowest number at the first difference.
Lucas.
Why?
So you can actually build it as you go instead of just saying,
yeah,
so you don't have to do all the work and going through the whole thing and they
added them all up and so on.
You just go to you,
you've got a difference.
And when you get a difference,
that's it.
That's much quicker.
Okay.
So we'll go to the first difference,
lowest number at the first difference and now we have to say,
now we know we have the chain and it's numbers and now we say where are the
various substituents are.
But first we have to name the substituents.
Now in the top you can see we have methyl Bromo,
methyl ethyl and chloro.
Yeah.
Now had we followed Sophie,
right?
We would have to name that one.
And that's not as easy to name.
So the fewer substituents that you have,
the harder they are to name.
Because they get more complicated,
right?
So that's why you choose to have the most substituents.
So there'll be the easiest to name,
you have to do more,
but it's easier.
That particular one is called one chloro Ethel.
But why have to main complicated things if you've been named simple things.
Okay,
so you choose the most substituents in order to get simpler names,
then you alphabetize them.
You don't put them on by order or their number,
you alphabetize the names of the groups and you and you count.
So that compound is seven Bromo be his first two,
Claro,
Si three Ethel,
six,
seven die methyl,
no name.
Now you might say die methyl should be alphabetized by d,
Not by em.
But that's not the way it's done.
It's done by the group name.
And then the,
the,
uh,
the prefix that tells the,
the,
uh,
number doesn't enter in to the,
to the alphabetizing usually,
although some people do it the other way.
Okay?
So,
uh,
so that's the question about the deed.
Okay.
Now if you go to this website,
you can get help with nomenclature.
Here's a compound that it goes through.
And the minute you look at this and see the name at the bottom,
the compound name,
four or five dy chloro to,
for chloro,
two hydroxy mouth,
all five oxo Hexcel cyclohexane one carboxylic acid,
you'd say,
wow,
and aren't you glad there are computers that can do this for you?
But you can go through it,
uh,
and figure out why they did it that way.
But,
but,
you know,
that's sort of a parlor game.
It's not fundamental chemistry.
Okay.
But there's some very useful non systematic names for simple groups.
Iso,
butane,
ISO,
Pentane,
neo pentane.
So you can have an ISO butyl group or an ISO Pendle group or a neopentyl group.
Ice approachable secondary,
butyl tertiary,
butyl neopentyl.
So these names you just have to learn,
right?
They're not systematic.
Yeah.
Uh,
and there's a nomenclature w drill available on the course website,
so it's good to know these so we can talk to one another.
But in principle,
the systematic name is the way to go.
Okay.
That's it.
Yeah.
But we haven't gotten to stereochemistry yet.
That'll be tomorrow or Monday.
Yeah.